dallas caico
having a real good start to his white
sox career you see the major league
record anytime you're 15 over 500 you
are getting it done
swinging a miss strike three it was a
change up
one gone struck him out
another change up
two wiped away on the change up and two
gone
win that saw young award that year and
this will go to first
the yell of cover is on but jose is
going to take it himself and there is
adrian hauser he is familiar with this
mound he just pitched on this mound was
something that might be in the cards too
as this goes to shortstop rc has got a
hustle and robert gets there safely
that's the pressure he puts on a defense
isn't it he can't use as an excuse to
lay off
big fastball upstairs and a strikeout
for hauser two balls two strikes to
count robert goes and
pina's throw is on the bag and in time
wow what a throw right on the money how
about that manny pina quick release
grand all on the first pitch
a little slow roller out to first base
and that will retire the side
called strike three he pumped in a
sinker on the inside corner and dallas
kykel has all ground balls and
strikeouts
so far
mark mathias
his first big league at bat just wonder
what must be going through his head
right now exciting to get himself to the
big leagues and how about it a base head
for matthias
in his first big league at bat and you
can hear the brewers dugout cheering for
him yeah good for him
save that ball mark matthias
has a hit in the major leagues against a
former cy young award winner yeah right
you're talking about one of the best in
the business and matthias able to get
the base hit doing a good job he waits
back waits back long enough and gets
just enough of it got it down on the end
a little bit but
kept that bat in a hitting zone nice
level swing for a base hit brewers have
something cooking here in the third
inning with first and second and nobody
out the 01
swung on and our base hit to center
field sogard's going to deliver a run
batted in for the brewers as matthias
scores it's one nothing milwaukee
bouncer laying out for it
jerko makes a play nicely done
he's been impressive handy defensively
badass and the socks trailing by one but
here's a good reason to believe that
deficit won't last all night long the
five hardest hit balls in this game have
all come off the bats of white sox
hitters yeah down and away slider right
yeah had to really concentrate get the
feet in position gammel makes the play
just in front of the wall gammel
takes a hit away from illi jimenez
sogard makes the play and adrian hauser
is just mowing down the white sox
third base side fair
danny mendick ripples one down the line
and he's digging for two
all it took was that footage and the sox
have a runner in scoring position
3-2 pitch and down he goes he got him
that time and he chased a fastball out
of the strike zone
on the ground slowly hit it will not get
out of the infield so mendic has to stay
at third but the sox have two on with
two out and jose abreu in another big
spot see what he does the o2 pitch a
curveball got him beauty when hauser
just like that gets out of trouble
here's the o2 swing in the miss strike
three inning over
eight strikeouts for dallas kykel
through seven innings of work
nothing game
this has been fun tonight kykel and
hauser 1-1 pitch bouncing ball up the
middle right there sogard step on the
back throw to first in time another
double play wow that's a third of the
night for adrian hauser
and he's kept this heavy hitting white
sox team down one-two pitch on its way
from adrian hauser
struck him out swinging
seven scoreless innings from adrian
hauser on the south side of chicago
hater in for his third appearance
he's got a save and he's gonna have to
earn it
going through abreu rondoll him
he was late
fly ball to right gamel settles under it
and a big out to get out number one as
abreu
one two pitch
high fly
left field playable matthias long run
nearing the line and he makes the catch
in his first big league start
playing a new position for the first
time
able to make that catch on the left
field line for out number two
haters got him to two strikes two outs
ninth inning one nothing he deals it and
a swing and a miss hater closes the door
and the brewers win tonight
one to nothing what a gem tonight on the
south side